hi I'm currently going through a hard
time as a first-time mom with a nine
month old I feel depressed and anxious
and I'm highly neurotic and volatile can
you suggest anything to help me be a
better mom well you know lots of people
have a hard time with their nine months
old I guess the first question would be
are you getting enough sleep do you have
enough help
are you eating enough especially in the
morning you know and you're gonna feel
highly neurotic and volatile to some
degree because well you've been through
quite a physiological trauma and it's
very demanding to have a newborn baby so
the best thing I could say not knowing
you is to make sure that you have people
around that you can talk to about your
baby and that you can and and that you
can take a break when you need to and
have someone spell you I mean that's
often the role that a husband plays in
the first year of a baby's life is that
he can he's supposed to watch the mother
to make sure that she doesn't get
overwhelmed by the demands of the baby
and so I would hope that you're able to
ask for support when you need it and not
to be afraid of asking for support
especially to get a rest and to get
something to eat because that's really
important especially in the morning
other than that I can't tell you
anything really specific unfortunately
given that I don't know anything about
the specifics of your situation if it
gets out of hand you know what you
should go the other thing I should say
is if it gets out of hand you should go
speak with your with your doctor with
the professional because you might have
postpartum depression there's some
dispute about whether that exists and as
an independent diagnostic entity but you
can certainly be physiologically
stressed and if you have a
predisposition to depression then that
kind of physiological stress and sleep
disruption can bring it on so I would
say if it really gets out of hand don't
hesitate to go talk to someone
professional you know it's it may be
necessary to do that because you don't
want to fall too far down the hall
that's for sure